y llegamos hasta la ciudad de estambul
ahí está nuestro corresponsal adrián
rocha porque se espera la llegada a
turquía del príncipe saudita mohammad
bin salman adrià muy buena tarde para
usted le preguntó entonces qué se espera
de este encuentro con el presidente
receta y perdón y cuál es el contexto de
esta visita del príncipe heredero
buenos días de raúl pues se esperan
varias cosas sobre todo que ambos países
entren en unas relaciones económicas
sobre todo económicas mucho más
estrechas que han sido hasta la fecha
recordemos que estos dos países turquía
y arabia saudita llevan enfrentados casi
una década ahora hace una década a
través del apoyo a que turquía brindó a
los países ya los grupos de los hermanos
musulmanes vinculados con qatar el país
gran rival de arabia saudí en la zona
del golfo pérsico y turquía necesita
este apoyo económico además arabia
saudita necesita que turquía en turquía
entierre las anchas en lo que respecta
al asesinato en octubre de 2018 de el
periodista saudí llama al peso que
recordemos que fue asesinado después de
entrar al consulado se puede ser
estambul a este periodista trabajaba
para the washington post de medio
estadounidense intentaba unos
papeles para poder poder casarse con su
prometida turca en ese mismo consulado
fue detenido asesinado y según explicó
la policía turca en ese momento un
descuartizado por los saudíes que fueron
enviados según la inteligencia
estadounidense
la onu por el mismo príncipe heredero
hermosamente shaman que hoy precisamente
llega tranquila para intentar demostrar
que tú quieras' adif dejan de estar
enemistados como han sido hasta la fecha
y buscarán pasar dicen ellos mismos
página a un nuevo capítulo en el futuro
que puedan vincular más las dos grandes
naciones junto con irán de oriente
próximo también le quiero preguntar a
díaz y puede leerse esta visita y esta
retoma digamos relaciones en una clave
de los intereses electorales del
presidente radwán
clarísimamente es el gran motivo por el
cual a turquía está intentando acercarse
a árabes hacia otros países de la zona
como también es israelí los emiratos
árabes unidos- y roban está en un mínimo
de popularidad histórico nunca antes del
presente turco que es el líder del país
desde 2003 han tenido índices de
popularidad tan bajos y según la gran
inmensa mayoría de las encuestas incluso
empresas encuestadoras favorables al
gobierno dicen que erdogán perdía cuando
la oposición en caso de que las
elecciones fuesen ya mismo y fuesen unas
elecciones limpias y democráticas por lo
tanto erdogán el gran motivo de este
desfallecimiento de su cualidad es la
gran crisis económica que vive de
turquía con una infracción cada parte
hablaba es antes de un 9 por ciento de
repente año turquía solamente ahora
ahora actualmente en un 70 por ciento
oficialmente según datos de otras
empresas la inflación real es ciento 140
150 por ciento y está afectado muchísimo
al popular garante y quiere acuerdos
económicos con países ricos del golfo
como en este caso debe ser y lo que
podría
a un
aflojamiento de la crisis económica
turca que podría conseguirle alberto con
una dirección más el año que viene el
periodo electoral más importante que
viene para la historia de turquía en los
últimos 20 30 o 40 años